[Music]
which house keys so good to have you
back at Warner Brothers well what can I
say Lana and I have wanted to work with
you guys again for a long time
wait are we doing this right what do you
mean
I mean wanna used to be Larry's so
should we get a man to play the part no
she's a woman now so it makes sense but
she used to be a man yeah but we don't
have any women who used to be men I
think Jim used to be a woman but turn
into a man really I don't know he said
it when he was drunk would that really
work though because he's a man now but
he's a transsexual doesn't make more
sense I have a woman who's not a
transsexual or transsexual that's a
transsexual the other way around look
I'm pretty sure it won't matter if we
don't address it Internet that never
works okay we all play different genders
before though so clearly we don't have a
problem with it yeah but it's like the
first real-life transsexual were
representing I just mommy tried don't
piss anybody off oh you mean like
because I'm black in because she's a
woman we suddenly represent all blacks
and all women exactly whoa who says that
everybody
[Applause]
we apologize for losing track of this
sketch we're going to assume that you
just want to see a review of Jupiter
ascending please note that we do not
discriminate against the Wachowskis for
anything except that they made Jupiter
ascending we now return to a hopefully
more focused routine so much housekeys
what did you have in mind well something
big and expensive big shot you know Star
Wars The Phantom Menace oh that gigantic
piece of awesomeness we loved it too
that's why we want you'll feel exactly
like that except we want to replace all
the boring dialogue and exposition with
even more boring dialogue and exposition
that sounds incredibly backward oh but
you know how all the characters took
themselves too seriously nobody like
that making the story seem more
important than it really is amazingly
unpopular when really they're just a
person who's bored with their lives who
discovers that they're amazing I
literally saw that on the Disney Channel
that's our story oh and their spaceship
been done rocket boots in done huge
computer-generated background am I even
the room right it's so much backstory it
made-up names you'll feel more like
homework that I will entertainment okay
you clearly have a story this twenty
years behind is made of mostly born
dialogue rips off every sci-fi movie
known to man and you want millions of
dollars from us after several critical
and box office failures how the hell did
you get money from us 170 million sound
roll Rus
and go
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to what
does it take to make a great epic oddly
enough the answer might not be as
complicated as you think introduce
character or characters make them
interesting and identifiable and put the
may a challenging journey that will
alter who they are by the end of the
story some do this well others not so
much but most would agree those are the
essential elements but then you get the
writers who think it should be focused
on other elements by complicated details
and backstories made-up names that sound
cool in some environments but fucking
ridiculous and others giant fake
explosions over giant fake landscapes
with people going ah and of course
people looking really really serious and
never smiling once because we can
identify with them easier that way sadly
some writers out there think this is
what makes a big epic and the Wachowskis
are a perfect example of that yeah I
know I picked on them a lot recently but
I'm sorry it's just too damn easy they
keep making the same mistakes over and
over these are people so convinced that
they can do epics well that they tried
to make a cartoon about a car a boy and
his monkey epic they made up their own
bullshit language to look important even
though nobody could follow what the hell
they were saying and of course they
spent over a hundred and seventy million
dollars on one of their biggest bombs
ever
Jupiter sent
who needs likeable characters or an
understanding what's going on we got big
sounding words people who whisper half
their lines while screaming the rest and
literally so many ripoffs of other
sci-fi films that listing them would
probably take up the entire review so I
am officially setting up outside pod of
annoyance just to go over all the movies
this film is obviously ripping off while
I go through the review
it's the Wachowski so you know there's a
lot to get through let's take a gander
at Jupiter ascending the movie opens
with a narration from our main character
played by Mila Kunis technically
speaking I'm an alien shut up Meg my
parents met at the University in Saint
Petersburg her parents are happy that a
bouncing baby boy is on the way but
suddenly a bunch of thugs come in to
kill the father why you may ask for no
money yep
really you don't need any more than that
just Volpone he could have used that
money to cure cancer or used it to smoke
kittens heads it's just the money you
get it it explains so much about the
character in the situation
yeah don't worry though this is the only
time you'll wish they went into more
detail in fact save for this moment
you'll find it's a curious rarity
somewhere in the middle of the Atlantic
she pushed me out
I was born without a country without a
home without a script either with
Jupiter rising at twenty-three degrees
ascendant this is supposed to mean that
I am destined for great things and that
I will find the one true love of my life
mmm
still sound stupid you could say that
name means dinosaurs fighting sharks
with laser nipples it still never gonna
fly I think it's a good name who are you
the voice actors for Sailor Jupiter how
random
so naturally a beautiful woman named
Jupiter gets the only job a beautiful
woman named Jupiter would get janitor if
only high-paying jobs favorite hot
people we think cut too I think
bounty hunters who are looking for you
know what I'm just gonna play a game
with you it's called try to care
no really just listen to these clubbing
fry guys for a couple seconds and see if
you can give a shit so what's going on
really try try to get invested another
hunter and ex Legion for the sky check
what you know the boots there was a
hunter in addition like a single gene
Natalia you see it's impossible
they're just saying stuff not speaking
dialogue saying stuff there's a big
difference they're just trying to say
important sound the exposition that
we've heard in a million films before
there's nothing original about it gee
are they all gonna fire the guy and miss
to notice stop asking if stupid stuff
will happen because then stupid stuff
will happen
well at least he has this episode one
shield while reenacting the Masters of
the Universe movie pop-up that's what
the tripod is for keep it focused we
then cut to well I would have said wave
and doll but both work as we're
introduced to one of our villains named
Balaam played by Academy Award winner
Eddie Redmayne a decision we're rapidly
regretting I'm not even kidding this is
how he sounds throughout the entire film
what was necessary to mr. Neary's double
our security deployment destroyed your
confess your genetic incapacity it's
incredible it's like we're listening to
the fucking godpigeon the Capuchin says
if you're gonna wear tight lever you
better expect laughs meanwhile one
Jupiter's friend / client it's asking
for advice on an outfit damn just trying
to sneak in a horny underwear shot like
most sci-fi movies these days but the
most phoned in aliens farted out the
cliched anus arrived doing honestly I
don't know I think they're like men's
rights activists this is just what they
do when they see a woman for the first
time Jupiter does what any person would
do when they see their best friend in
danger take a picture when the aliens
suddenly erased their memories but that
doesn't stop her from discovering the
picture later and having absolutely no
reaction to it oh just another night of
anal groping by unknown life-forms that
might be ffs or as I like to call it
Tuesday but Jupiter can't think of this
now as she's going to a fertility clinic
to get some extra money to buy a
telescope nope really that's one of the
subplots why is it you get 10 grand and
I get 5 I mean they're not your age
that's capitalism babe profits flow up
and just to be clear this is the comedic
part of the film folks get it where the
aliens attack again even though they
probably could have just done this the
last time they saw
she's saved by a man named Kane played
by Channing Tatum who takes her to the
Sears Tower because I'm sure no security
would be at that place it can be
difficult people from underdeveloped
worlds to hear that their planet is not
the only inhabited planet in the verse
we're a species so advanced we call the
universe the verse behold as I prepared
to shorten your most popular orange
drink to Sunny D news reaches Michael
Crawford's falsetto who doesn't seem
very happy with the news destroy any
ship that comes Christ I hope it doesn't
sporadic Lee scream like that on date
night hey what do you say we what what
Tatum tells her that she is needed
elsewhere in the verse and they almost
have what I guess is a romantic scene
but we don't really know anything about
these characters therefore you can't
feel any chemistry so I'll just point
out how they're ripping off Superman
Returns but hey at least we now know
somebody watched Superman Returns but
more Calista Flockhart aliens are on the
prowl and they have actually a pretty
decent chase throughout most of Chicago
but it goes on for so fucking long that
you wish they would bump into better
Chicago action scenes look out for the
Joker
the city though is immediately fixed and
the aliens wipe all of the people's
memories Tatum is hurt pretty bad but
thankfully Jupiter has a maxi pad I
don't even know what kind of joke to
make about that before when you need to
stop bleeding from more places than what
no it's too weird I got nothing he takes
her to his good friend stinger played by
Sean fuck you I'm not gonna die in
another role beep they decide to fight
each other because they really like that
cliche of two old friends meeting again
and not getting along come on even
earnest say Christmas did that one but
Jupiter distracts them with her
incredible power of stupid things
[Music]
Majesty so why did the bees obey her get
a lot of this no bees are genetically
designed to recognize royalty they sense
it you know not go away I'm having
trouble with this one the whole movie it
is so so really strange I'm having
trouble coming up with stuff to say
about it
we have naked clip keepers climbing the
wall maxi pants uses band-aids and now
bees that recognize royal tarts and
they're treating a little bit like it's
just common knowledge it's like anything
normal you'd find in any other great
epic is there anything else so amazingly
stupid you practically make it
impossible to comment on your people
kill the dinosaurs technically they're
your people majesty you know give me
just give you content on the scene wait
because this will be so high on itself
only a drug addict to respond to it your
people kill the dinosaurs technically
they're your people majesty oh I bet
they also create the parallel dimension
in the Super Mario Brothers movie
that'll go get out of here that's off it
makes sense ah actually it does kind of
make sense
[Applause]
you
so I hope you really like someone asking
a question and someone else answering it
cuz you're in for a great big fucking it
he had wings by a neural synaptic
prosthetic the military goodbye why
won't those human beings share things
like this sharing has never been this
strong suit of your species
you see mad at me splicer that bred a
man to sell into the Legion for a loss I
don't care next scene why did he get
court-martialed
it's nice name so I could I don't care a
next name do you know what this will do
I don't think that most people oh my god
this is bitch-ass dangerous human
predator course are gone obviously
before any colonization or resource
development could be done safely to your
planet large-scale extinction it you
know this is like instead of
experiencing the awesomeness of Lord of
the Rings you're instead forced to hear
the appendix throughout most of it was
brought from the Hornburg ever after the
white tsumugu there was sickly
if you do not stop rise you'll be forced
to close the book and do something
[Applause]
suddenly oh no something not talking
related is about to happen
hey take your shirt off and let's get
going they tried to outrun the intruders
by fleeing into the field but they
managed to grab her and take her away
well so remember folks the next time you
see a crop circle in a cornfield it's
not a bunch of pretentious attention
seekers who could be doing something
better with their time
it's the Wachowski so she's taken
apparently to a safe part of gophers
well the person who demanded her
kidnapping seems surprisingly not
harmful i'm kalique it's you're better
Jones stop the film stop the film she is
not named Jupiter Jones it's impossible
it is actually a mental impossibility
for anyone to give someone a goddamn
idiotic first and last name like that
and expect to be taken seriously do you
not have that alarm in your head I don't
know if you know this but every human
being has an alarm in their head to
prevent something like this from
happening so if you're saying you keep
Arden tight because well I don't know
something like Jupiter Jones this little
arm goes off thinking fucking stupid
stop fucking stupid stop hell of it I'm
just calling her duck Dodgers I honestly
can't take that fucking name more
seriously than Jupiter goddamn idiot
Jones unless she's a space cowgirl with
a laser lasso riding a rocket horse that
name will never work call me when you
name her mercury moxie so the ruler of
this realm tells duck Dodgers that she
is the reincarnation of her mother and
that it's Dodgers responsibility to be
Queen once more there I said that in one
sentence why does it take the movie ten
minutes to explain that genes have an
almost spiritual significance they are
the seeds of
same genes reappear in the exact same
order it is for us what you were call
reincarnation my mother was born before
your first cities were built the
difference between us is unknown this
movie is like school I'm in fucking
school common for people in the first
estate to leave a trust for any
potential recurrence memos the title to
you mr. critic what did we just say Oh
government space gargoyles live long and
prosper see me after class we tried to
break up the scene of it by showing
Tatum busting in to save her but even
that doesn't seem to get in the way of
their fucking talking well he has
contacted the aegis oh I got a gun
they're entering orbit no it's pretty
badass I have to myself ok I killed a
lot of guards in honor of their memory
you should at least turn and acknowledge
that I'm here Tatum finds out her
kidnappers aren't evil thus him at duck
Dodgers share what I guess is a romantic
moment as he talks about his wolf-like
qualities I must bless you don't
understand what that means but I have
more in common with a dog than I have
with you not that I want to rewind
anything in this movie but could we hear
that line again ok this is a new breed
of dumb like this is kind of a discovery
if you were to take the pretentious
awkwardness of sha Millan and mix it
with of a Bulls incomprehension of
reality you would have this brand new
species of fuckery we're tampering with
terrible that has never been tampered
with before we are witnessing the birth
of a new dome it's actually kind of
beautiful could you say that line again
is if you're verifying that you wrote an
actual funny line I love dogs
oh it's actually bringing the tear to my
eye is there a way to put you in a frame
movie so you'll be happy to know that
all that talking and exposition has been
building up to something even more
exciting than that standing in line to
filling out paperwork yeah for reals
they have to authenticate her title as
Queen which involves them waiting for
hours and filling out various forms now
to the credit the scene is Morneau Maj
to the sci-fi classic Brazil that is a
ripoff I know this not only from a
similar visual style and tone but also
having its director Terry Gilliam cameo
and even quoting an exact line of techno
jargon you are interact by a shooting of
statue 27b stroke 6 have you go to 27b
stroke 6 but even that goes on forever
you can practically count your brain
cells popping every second it's on
screen 32 33 34 so she gets her stamp of
Queen eNOS sniffing it smells like women
when duck Dodgers suddenly realizes
maybe she doesn't want to be queen yeah
good timing to come to that conclusion I
will admit there are things about my
life that I would like to change but
doesn't make me a different person it
doesn't it doesn't change the things
that mattered to me or who I care about
like cleaning toilets and hating my life
is there something I need tea right now
does any part of you want to buy me
oh you know lana wachowski now that
you've made the transition into becoming
a woman and you've been very brave
coming out about it and trying to raise
awareness and really standing up for
transsexual rights I mean good for you
and I really need that all honesty
fantastic wonderful job you should be
very proud but now that you are a woman
don't you think you could write them a
bit better I mean this character has
done nothing throughout the entire film
her biggest contribution so far is
asking if she could have a different
dress actually know what I'm feeling a
little overdressed so if you maybe have
something that I could change into she
said nothing interesting done nothing
interesting she's just a complete and
useless tool all she's done so far is
get kidnapped oh why don't you just have
her get kidnapped again she seems to be
really good at that are you fucking
kidding me don't make this harder than
telling you to toughen up parties bella
is making fun of you so a person who
kidnaps her is the brother of the last
person who kidnapped her and they
partake in what do you think even more
talking but I know what you're thinking
what the fuck are they gonna talk about
now that they've used every word in the
goddamn English language eyebrows I was
very close to my mother that I could
tell by the way she raised her eyebrows
exactly what she was thinking that's
right they're so desperate to talk
they're even fucking eyebrows become
that subject matters what makes you
think kalique told you the truth why
would she lie kalique is in competition
with the land same can be said for you
shut up shut up Jesus Christ man what
the hell is wrong would you please just
shut up fuck so if I'm following it
correctly hey give me some credit it's
not the easiest thing to do he says he
can take over her queenly duties if she
marries him so it's kind of like
marrying her son that's messed up not
realizing that he plans to kill her
after the wedding
so Tatum has to stop the beautiful love
interest from marrying the evil bad
guy as he blessed through a bunch of
ships to stop the ceremony it's like if
roland emmerich directed the graduate he
was going to murder you I don't believe
my mother was ever as beautiful or as
gullible as you my dear well that was a
complete waste of time what are we gonna
do now okay I'm just gonna give you a
heads up you need to be sitting down for
this I'm not okay if you're standing up
or you're walking like this on your
phone or tablet stuff like hey you need
to sit down cuz this is actually kind of
amazing it's actually kind of beyond
belief
what they do next are you ready are you
sitting now you're comfortable you're
good you need pillow hmm what do they do
next the exact same goddamn thing again
by Jesus I wish I was joking honest a
cock it's beyond belief
but they literally repeat the exact same
storyline that they just told us the
doctors again is Kenneth a brother of
the first kidnapper is again the one
that does it he wants to get his hands
on her through some legal ceremony and
Tatum once again has to come in to save
her the only difference is this guy
wants to destroy all life on Earth and
has kidnapped your family to force her
to say yes but aside from that the
following 20 minutes is an exact carbon
copy of the last 20 minutes oh my god I
should be angry
I should be fuming with rage that they
actually thought they could take the
exact same plot line they just fucking
gave us and they give it to us again
insultingly thinking that we somehow
wouldn't notice but at this point it
doesn't matter I am watching Valhalla
fall it's so grand in its destruction so
puzzling in its death so divine in its
failure that it really is a mind-blowing
spectacle to behold it is beautiful and
heinous all at the same time an
incredible mixture of
and Armageddon all we need to top off
this explosion of mediocrity is a
performance so bad it will be our
Brunhilde riding the winged horse into
the flames Eddie will you be our
Brunhilde I create
I will is done
yep the majority of this final act all
belongs to him and by God does he do
well at whispering that final nail into
position and screaming it down into the
coffin it is quite literally a miracle
of bad you know as entertaining as he is
I really do have to ask how could this
performance come from an Academy Award
winner
you don't understand critic it's so I
could join the league yes the league of
good actors who give one batshit crazy
performance but that's a thing oh yes
every talented actor has to give at
least one totally awful performance in
their lifetime remember Jimmy I won so
many awards it doesn't matter what I do
[Music]
hundred and one Dalmatians that's what
drew me to it's Michael Sheen only to
those who nominated me for frost/nixon
but to the rest of the world and that
crazy ass from Twilight was born
frost/nixon
Oh Frank Langella you're in here too yes
in one of my favorite roles as Skeletor
because as we all know the higher the
screen the higher the bank stack
so duck Dodgers figures yeah like a
little of humanity died just to save my
family that seems the least selfish when
Tatum somehow all by himself gets
through the most high-tech royal
security in the hearse and even manages
to destroy his entire kingdom as well
the power of fucking one I guess is this
a trick question
gee I'm just gonna take a wild guess and
say that Tatum saves her yeah it's okay
though he wants to take her to yet a
fourth sibling who wants to marry her
and take control of earth as well
they're kind of like Starbucks around
here so duck Dodgers finally decide she
can be queen at home while also cleaning
toilets
I think the stupidity of that speaks for
itself
Hey look Clarence even got his wings and
I swear to God not even kidding there
was even more story than that in this
film but I simply don't have time to go
over it yes a lot of epics have big
talks and complicated storylines but the
story of King Arthur works because we
see our flaws and strengths in the
character Star Wars works because we
like these people and want to see them
get through a life but we're with them
when they're thrown in these complex and
dangerous worlds here you don't care
about anybody so you don't care about
the backstories are the made-up worlds
it attempts instead to sound big
instead of feel big it tries too hard in
lesser areas and not hard enough in the
ones that really matter if there is one
thing that's epic in this film is what
an epic disaster it gave us in the end
it really is the Valhalla
of botched epic stories I'm a nostalgia
critic and I'm off to play Donkey Kong
to get a more epic story ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
now give me party over there a party or
Jupiter oh yeah oh I love it oh yes now
take an hour to turn into your outfit
yes there you go there you go no this
isn't working you're fired
I love dogs I've always left